the Mexican drug war has become a lot
bloodier than most Americans understand
because it's basically never covered
here here the facts more than 23,000
people were murdered in Mexico just last
year as drug cartels continue to fight
each other and the Mexican government
meanwhile drugs continue to pour across
the American border in massive amounts
killing tens of thousands of Americans
now fear of letting this chaos into our
country is one of the reasons the Trump
administration is called for tougher
immigration laws and a border wall not
everybody is on board to put it mildly
we recently discussed this issue with
Jorge Ramos he's a Univision anchor and
champion of the oppressed south of the
border here it is when last we spoke you
said that the United States has 11
million illegal immigrants within its
borders because of supply and demand and
it's America's fault that these people
are here they were lured by jobs but
there's a flip side to it which is that
the remittance is paid by Mexican
citizens back to Mexico are the largest
source of cash in Mexico higher than its
oil export revenue that is true so
Mexico desperately needs American money
sent back by illegal aliens here why
shouldn't we blame the government of
Mexico for that well first of all I
don't call them illegal aliens no human
being is illegal people who are here
illegally they're illegal well they're
here but we don't call illegal companies
those who hire them so I don't wait for
me leave it you can you can use it it's
actually the legal term in the US
government documents so I'm just gonna
go ahead and go with the accurate
description but and I'll go up with a
moral point of view that you should not
call anyone you are legal and I'm gonna
go ahead and not be bullied and just
call them whatever but but the point is
look the governor of Mexico couldn't
exist without them that's the point
well they do get billions of dollars
from from Mexican citizens in the United
States that is true but but the point is
that undocumented immigrants are here
soccer because of us we need them you
might want to admit it or not but we
need them
it's simply a matter of supply and
demand whenever you go to write or
service or to a hotel or to a restaurant
we are being served by them though no I
know we're big on lecturing Americans of
their feelings but what about getting
real feelings to the Mexican government
which is corrupt parts of your control
but the drug cartels it doesn't serve
the needs of its own people and it
hasn't for almost a hundred years and
yet it's a hundred percent America's
fault and not the fault of the Mexican
government which uses the illegal
immigration as a pressure relief valve
that's that's what's happening and you
know it yeah I I think it shows the
wrong guess to to defend the Mexican
government because I've been criticizing
the Mexican government for decades I
have a Mexican government if it is
really corrupt in the last year I was
checking the numbers more than 20,000
people have been killed because of
violence in Mexico and we're going to
have elections in Mexico in July the
first and I hope that that that changes
but I'm I'm no one to defend the Mexican
government
there's a lack of democracy there's a
lack of transparency there's a lot of
corruption there's really nothing to
defend about the president but in effect
you are because you're saying that our
illegal immigration problems are our
fault when in fact abetting illegal
immigration is the policy of the Mexican
government what a single largest source
of heroin in the United States is Mexico
the leading cause of death for people
under 50 is heroin OD so why shouldn't
we be angry at the government of Mexico
for allowing this to happen here well
because there's a different way of
seeing that you were seen as Mexico is
responsible for the drugs coming to this
country and there's way people in Mexico
and the way people in Colombia and in
other Latin American countries the way
they see it is that as long as you have
20 to 25 million Americans who use
continuously illegal drugs there's again
a problem supply in the men and it
doesn't matter what you do at the border
it doesn't matter if you have a huge
wall drugs are going to keep on coming
so it's so that's what's a drug dealer
tells himself this is not my fault the
junkies for right so if you flood a
community with illegal drugs do you
think drug use and Odie's go up I mean
that's a weird question because the
answer is of course yes so why I mean
why plainly mixing in here I don't
understand no it's not the way
Vampira if you have 20 or 25 million
americans would use an illegal drug in
the past in the last month what are you
gonna do I mean only because if I
dropped a ton of heroin into your zip
code do you think you would see a higher
rate of heroin addiction and do you
think that would be their children and
your neighbors no it would be not only
that you drop it the fact is that people
are asking for that for cheap heroin
yeah no I mean look let's be honest not
building a wall is not making the
problem better people are dying and as a
result of it that the will would be
completely useless let's take a look at
walls through history how many have been
useless
let's see not let me let me give you
just a few arguments here according to
the Pew Research Center almost 45% of
all undocumented immigrants come by
plane or with a visa so it doesn't
matter how long or wide what percent
almost almost 45% you can check it so
what about I think I think that numbers
right I think that numbers right but
there's still half a million people more
than apprehended at the border every
year on foot that doesn't account for
all people who made it across you have
hundreds of thousands people coming at
some unknown number coming across with
no wall and you have tons and tons of
drugs so why is it immoral to try and
stop that because the the idea that you
are giving your audience and the idea
that President Trump is is giving the
American people is that we are being
invaded but Mexico that is not - more
Mexicans actually are leaving the United
States and I'm not saying we're being
invaded I'm saying tons of drugs and
thousands of people or I'm not saying
there is I'm saying there's noises of
heroin and hundreds of thousands of
people are coming across and they many
of them will be stopped by the wall so
why is it immoral to put a lock on our
front door I don't understand why why
should everybody be scolded for wanting
to protect our own country I don't get
that I agree with you every single
country has the right to secure borders
I have no problem I have no problem with
that
Wow that the wall the president from
wants to build and apparently you're
supporting would be completely useless
first of all there's no ambition coming
from Mexico second it's not true that
hundreds of thousands of people are
coming to this country because the
undocumented population the undocumented
population has remained stable in this
country for the last decade and anther
Mexico for so we don't really know what
the undocumented so-called population is
because they're here legally no no no no
as a true we do that senseless you've at
least could be twenty we don't know but
they're more than ten million eleven
Mara legally they're clear illegally
eleven mean we'll say eleven nine you
know people are living proof that we
don't have control of our border and I
hope the others summing up for me one
sentence cuz worrying at the time why is
it a bad idea to build a wall to stop
some percentage of those people some
percentage of the heroin when every
other wall in every other country on
planet Earth has had an effect in
stopping people and drugs from getting
into the country
it separates I don't understand because
it's a myth to believe that the border
right now is more insecure it's it's a
myth and then again as long as you have
millions of consumers of illegal drugs
in this country
drugs are gonna keep on coming from
ports of entry or through tunnels that's
one one comeback in okay that's that's
great
alright thank you for joining thank you
appreciate it thanks